les habitants du quartier de shevchenko
ce qu'ils n'avaient pas encore terminé
le café du matin quand ils ont d'abord
été ébloui par une lumière blanche puis
projetée par une explosion ils savent
que les combats se sont rapprochés de
chez eux mais à l'instar de gurat ils ne
veulent pas partir
bien sûr dire qu'on n'a pas peur ça
reste difficile mais c'est normal
maintenant dit il on s'est habitué
certains des habitants s'étaient
réfugiées ici après que leur village
était occupé par l'armée russe
pour d'autres c'est le souvenir d'une
guerre qu'on ne croyait plus jamais
revivre qui a été ravivée
valérie a survécu à l'occupation nazie
encerclé par les allemands tôt si mu 7 6
6 mais je russie lit pendant des mois
nous avons vécu dans un village encerclé
par les allemands nous les voyons mais
les allemands n'ont jamais fait ce que
des fascistes de russes pourront
maintenant dit elle elles ont largement
passé l'âge de devoir prendre les armes
mais ça ne les arrêtera pas dit
valentina nous sommes envoyés nous
acheter chiottes sérieuse une issue d'un
doute mais on va le défendre et lg des
bocaux de confiture je vais les prendre
et les frapper sur la tête
n'est pas pour elle qu'elle s'inquiète
dit ludmila
je ne peux pas penser au mal qui
pourrait arriver à mes enfants et petits
enfants je ne peux pas imaginer qu'il
puisse mourir alors qu'il commence à
peine à vivre et ses bâtards laitue je
veux que poutine ce bâtard meurt et se
retourner dans sa tombe sur certaines
c'est qu'après un mois guerre la russie
ménage pas la population civile ici un
complexe d'appartements encore bien
habité est derrière moi un jardin
d'enfants des cibles militaires par
contre autour on n'en voit pas
cet homme a été transporté d'urgence
dans un grand hôpital de la ville après
la frappe de ce matin il est sur la
table d'opération depuis plusieurs
heures son pronostic est sombre
nous avons arrêté l'hémorragie dix
médecins mais beaucoup de signes font
croire qu'il ne survivra pas
ici il ne reste presque plus de patients
réguliers ou de malades chroniques du
jour au lendemain le personnel soignant
s'est tourné vers la médecine de guerre
pour que des patients comme valera
puissent être sauvés
nous allions à vinnytsia chez ma grand
mère mais nous n'y sommes pas arrivés à
cause des russes dit la petite c'est
parce que notre voiture a explosé
valera et sa mère natacha fuyaient la
banlieue dire pin avec un convoi de
voitures qui identifiait clairement
qu'elle transportait des femmes et des
enfants mais l'armée russe a tout de
même tiré c'est au but we
move up de routine ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est un génocide
intentionnelle dit natacha c'est la
destruction de tous les russophones et
les ukrainiens nous sommes unis en
ukraine c'est pourquoi je pense que nous
n'avons pas le choix il nie la russie a
juste besoin de quitter
natacha et russophones et son père et
russe ni elle ni lui n'avait besoin
d'être secourue par la russie dit elle
aujourd'hui elles voudraient fuir mais
elle redoute de ne pouvoir être sauvé
que nous soyons mis au bonus miani
mourinho coumba diop j'ai peur dit
natacha mais je ne peut aller nulle part
physiquement
aujourd'hui sont quelques 300 civils à
être soignés comme natacha kiev pour des
blessures de guerre en plus de 16
enfants comme valérin depuis le début de
la guerre plus de 300 civils sont morts
dans la capitale selon la mairie
quatre enfants ont été tués
encore combien devez vous voir pour
arrêter de soutenir la russie avant de
l'isoler demande la dîmière klitschko
chaque scène qui va dans le budget de la
russie va servir à acheter des armes
soutient aujourd'hui et dans les
dernières semaines nous sommes nos
femmes et nos enfants combien de crimes
de guerre en plus voulez-vous voir les
frères klitschko ont l'habitude de se
mesurer à d'imposants adversaires quand
la russie a envahi l'ukraine beaucoup en
plus que les défenses de la capitale ne
ferait pas le poids face à l'armée de
vladimir poutine il serait vite terrain
c'est un mois plus tard qui elle réussit
encore à essuyer les coûts mais il ne
faut surtout pas baisser la garde a dit
l'un vitaly le maire de la ville la
russie pourrait encore leur infliger le
sort de karkhiv ou de mario paul
nous espérons on dit il mais nous savons
que ça peut arriver à notre ville c'est
la russie attaque et détruit toutes nos
infrastructures et la capitale de
l'ukraine
les lignes de francs bouge peu au
nord-ouest les forces du craignait n'ont
su rendre les coups mais plus à l'est et
au sud la russie se rapproche ils ne
seront pas assez nombreux à se battre si
kiev doit arriver à se relever avant le
compte
des rumeurs de la
mission de chaque homme est de défendre
une famille et les enfants dit il les
hommes qui ont conduit leurs enfants
sécurité doivent maintenant revenir pour
prendre les armes et défendre la ville
qui elle restera ukrainienne promet-il
mais la ville n'a pas fini de transpirer
et de saignée dans la bataille ici marie
ève bédard radio-canada kiev